Wir wollen blicken auf den europäischen Fußball heute in einer etwas kleineren Runde, als ihr es uns gewohnt seid. Mit Christian Bernhard sprechen wir über die Serie A, mit Jakob Haffke über die Liga und mit Chris McCarthy über die Premier League. Und genau jetzt geht's los. Und nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk.
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Es fühlt sich an, als hätte ich dieses Intro gerade erst gehört. Aber das muss eine Illusion sein. Ihr drei, schön, dass ihr hier seid. Schönen guten Morgen.
Boah, ja okay. Das sind beeindruckende Statistiken. Oberflächliche Analyse meinerseits. Chelsea hat den jüngsten Kader der Premier League, Durchschnittsalter 23 Jahre, sind die einfach alle noch zu grün unter den Ohren und sehen deshalb rot.
Es ist sicherlich ein Grund, aber es ist ziemlich auffällig, dass von sieben dieser neun roten Karten gegen einen Spieler, die über 24 sind. Das sind also nicht nur diese Erfahrungswerte. Es zieht sich einfach auch wie ein rotes Tuch durch die letzten Jahre. Da muss auch einfach was von den Trainern passieren. Mareska beschwerte sich darüber, jetzt Rosé Noir beschwerte sich darüber. Und wenn man sich diese gelben Karten und Platzverweise anschaut, es ist absolut unnötig. Und es ist nicht nur Erfahrung, es ist einfach teilweise dumm. Es sind Konzentrationsaussetzer. Und das spiegelt sich aber auch in einem weiteren Thema, unserem Thema der Woche, würde ich mal behaupten, Standards, nämlich wieder. Denn auch da beweist Chelsea Disziplinlosigkeiten. In den letzten, in den 13 Spielen unter Rosé Noir gab es sieben Tore, sieben Gegentore nach Standardsituation. Das ist ziemlich viel. Und dann schaut man sich diese Tore mal an und man sieht, wie oft Chelsea-Spieler einfach einen Mann übersehen, ihn vergessen, ihn stehen lassen. Und man merkt einfach, dass diese gesamte Chelsea-Mannschaft irgendwo ein Problem mit dem Fokus hat, mit der Konzentration hat. Und das spiegelt sich in den Standards wieder, das spiegelt sich in den roten Karten wieder. Und das ist eben das, was Rosé Noir auch meinte, dass man nicht wegen den Leistungen verliert. Denn Chelsea ist definitiv leistungstechnisch auf dem richtigen Weg unter ihm.
Aber wo würdest du denn jetzt dann von außen betrachtet da ansetzen? Beziehungsweise Jakob hat offenbar eine Idee. Jakob, kannst du lösen?
Ja, ich habe mir nur noch mal kurz den Kader von Chelsea angeguckt. Und es ist halt schon, glaube ich, oder es sieht für mich aus wie ein hausgemachtes Problem. Denn ich glaube, das, was Max angesprochen hat, ist irgendwie schon ein Problem. Vielleicht nicht unbedingt, dass nur die jungen Spieler vom Platz fliegen. Aber es gibt ja eigentlich keinen Führungsspieler im Kader. Also die ältesten Spieler sind, glaube ich, Tosi, aber Biojo und Robert Sanchez, die beide 28 sind. Und jetzt beide für mich auch nicht so nach, okay, wir führen jetzt die Mannschaft an, schreien.
Genau. Du bringst dich schon auf den Punkt, dass genau das wollte ich nämlich sagen. Es ist nicht mal das Problem, dass der gesamte Kader jung ist. Es fehlt wirklich an Führungsspielern. Und das hat auch Robert Hood kürzlich gesagt, das merkt man besonders bei den Standards. Es fehlt dieser Führungsspieler, dieser ruhige Leader, ein John Terry, ein Lampert ist ja auch Wurst. Wer aber jemand, der ein bisschen kühlen Kopf bewahrt, die Spieler ein bisschen dirigiert. Und man merkt einfach, dass zu viele Spieler zu jung, zu hektisch reagieren in gewissen Situationen. Und das ist ein hausgemachtes Problem, weil man eben auch diese Philosophie verfolgt. So viele junge Talente wie möglich zu verpflichten und mit Gewinn weiter zu verkaufen. Aber das direkte Resultat daraus ist einfach eine hohe Fluktuation. Und das führt eben auch dazu, dass du keine klare Hackordnung in diesem Kader hast. Und sowas muss ich ja auch einfach etablieren Jahr für Jahr. Und das hat Chelsea nicht. Und das sind ebenso, glaube ich, diese Nebeneffekte, die man bei Chelsea nicht wirklich auf dem Schirm hatte. Und den Preis zahlt man eben jetzt.
Christian? Ja, ich finde das total spannend, weil wir haben ja Chelsea auch schon oft thematisiert in den letzten Jahren hier. Wir wissen ja alle, wie viel Geld Chelsea in die Hand genommen hat. Was da auch immer auch die Breite im Kader hat man ja auch schon oft genug, dass da ja oft schon schwierig genug ist, quasi auf der Bank zu sitzen bei so viel individueller Qualität, die da immer auch wieder extern dazu geholt wird. Und dann finde ich es schon spannend. Klar, wir erkennen den Ansatz, gerade durch euch, durch eure tollen Hintergrundgeschichten aus der Premier League, was die Idee dahinter ist. Aber ich finde es schon spannend, dass es dann eben nicht auf dem Zettel zu haben oder zumindest nicht gewollt vielleicht auch nicht umzusetzen, dann doch die eine oder zweite Figur da halt doch mit reinzugeben, die vielleicht jetzt, wie du sagst Chris, vielleicht wird da schon einer helfen, der da ein bisschen Ordnung gibt, der einfach eine gewisse Historie mitbringt. Dadurch würde ich ja sagen, würde auch nicht dein ganzes Konzept über den Haufen geworfen, wenn du da vielleicht mal, sage ich jetzt mal einen 31-Jährigen reinstellst, der halt auch eine gewisse Erfahrung auf internationalen Niveau, das so mit sich bringt. Also ich finde, es ist ganz spannend, daran sieht man, wie stur dann manchmal auch solche Ansätze sind, weil niemand von uns würde ja verlangen, dass da jetzt plötzlich vier 34-Jährige geholt werden müssen. Aber vielleicht wird da eine oder der zweite da schon helfen, um all diesen jungen Talentierten halt auch ein bisschen eine Führung mitzugeben. Aber anscheinend ist es ja gewollt, weil ich glaube, an den finanziellen Mitteln wird es nicht liegen, da eventuell noch einen auch so dazuzuholen, oder?
Eben, absolut richtig. Und man sieht auch das allein am Trainerverschleiß. Denn man hat einmal Risken rausgeschmissen, der eigentlich gute Arbeit leistete, aber einfach daran verzweifelt ist, dass es wieder diese hohe Fluktuation gab, dass ihm auch reingepfuscht wurde in Sachen Aufstellungen, weil man will ja seine Investitionen schützen. Das haben wir schon mal in einer Folge angesprochen. Und man ordnet andere bzw. finanzielle Interessen dem sportlichen Erfolg einfach über. Man weiß, man hat hier diese Anlagen, diese Investitionen. Und im Optimalfall steigen die im Wert und dann werden sie irgendwann verkauft. Und das scheint so ein bisschen wichtiger zu sein.
Ja, und es ist so ein bisschen, glaube ich, auch das Football-Manager-Syndrom. Unter dem so Leute wie wir auch manchmal leiden, weil wir halt so analytisch auf den Sport blicken. In der Theorie sind Spieler zwischen 24 und 27 Jahren in ihrer Prime. Also gerade zu 27, 28 erreichen sie meist den Höhepunkt. Am billigsten kaufen kannst du mit 30. Weil dann psychologisch gesehen bei vielen so eine Transfer ablösen, Schalter sich umsetzt und dann kannst du einen Schnapper machen ab 30 Jahren. Aber in der Praxis ist es eben dann doch so, dass da elf Spieler, zehn Feldspieler in einem Stadion stehen vor Zehntausenden von Menschen, die einen enormen Druck ausgerichtet sind, denen auch gar nicht geholfen ist, dadurch, dass die viel Geld verdienen. Das spielt in solchen Situationen keine Rolle, sondern da kommt halt wirklich Psychologie rein. Und dann kommt nämlich so was wie Führungsspieler mit rein. Nicht jede Führungsspielerdebatte ist immer sinnvoll, weil manchmal liegt es nicht an Führungsspielern. Aber du brauchst sie auf dem Feld eben doch. Eben Spieler, an denen du dich ausrichten kannst. Ich habe neulich mit dem länger über das deutsche Nationalteam gesprochen und auch über deutschen Nachwuchsfußball. Da vielen sehr harte Urteile. Und da ging es aber unter anderem in diese Richtung. Dass das einfach so unterschätzt wird, wie wichtig es ist. Und mir sagen alle ehemaligen Spieler, ja das können nur Spieler beurteilen, die das mal auf dem Feld gesehen haben. Und natürlich würde ich am liebsten sagen, nein, ich sehe es doch in den Daten nicht. Dann kann es nicht da sein. Aber vielleicht muss man es auch einfach respektieren. Wenn eigentlich fast alle ehemaligen Spieler sagen, naja, das ist schon wichtig, dass du jemanden hast, an dem du dich ausrichten kannst. In verschiedenen Situationen. Und man darf nicht vergessen, wie viel Trash-Talk und Nicklichkeiten es trotz allem VLA und so weiter immer noch gibt. Gerade von älteren Spielern gegen jüngeren Spielern. Also ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass Chelsea auch durch seine Kaderstruktur so ein Team ist. Die sind halt auch so leichte Opfer. Da reichen halt zwei sehr erfahrene Spieler in der gegnerischen Mannschaft. Und die trieten in jeder Situation, steigen die ganze Zeit mit den Stollen auf den großen C. Und vielleicht kommt das dann auch noch mit dazu. Wollte ich nur ergänzen.
Absolut. Und man muss ja nur an die Vereinsspitze von Chelsea schauen. Da sitzt Todd Bowley, der hat einen Baseball-Hintergrund. Und das ist ja mit einer der analytischsten Sportarten, die es auf dieser Welt gibt. Und so wird auch dieser Kader oder dieser Verein aufgebaut derzeit. Und das ist eben auch kein Zufall. Und ich finde es auch kein Zufall, Jakob hat gerade die erfahrenen Spieler angesprochen. Und einer davon ist Robert Sanches im Tor. Und der ist ja zugegebenermaßen einfach nicht gut. Er ist ein Unsicherheitsfaktor. Und wenn einer der erfahrenen Spieler ein Unsicherheitsfaktor ist, der bei Standards dermaßen wackelig agiert und unsicher wirkt, das strahlt sich auch auf seine Mitspieler aus. Und es ist kein Zufall, dass Chelsea über eine Milliarde ausgegeben hat, ich glaube Richtung 2 sogar, und aber nicht sein Torhüter neu besetzt hat. Robert Sanches passt nicht zu den Ambitionen dieses Vereins. Und ja, aber warum denn? Weil mit Torhütern in der Regel auch nicht so viel Geld zu machen ist, wie mit Feldspielern. Das ist ja auch kein Zufall. Also, ja.
Ja, irgendwie ein bisschen tröstlich, dass man sich nicht doch alles am Whiteboard zusammenschustern kann. Ja, schauen wir mal, ob sie den Rekord noch brechen. Zwei Platzverweisen sind es noch. Schauen wir doch mal. Und wir schauen auch noch mal nach Frankreich. Und wir machen heute mal was Ungewohntes. Jakob, normalerweise gucken wir oft an die Spitze und in den Keller und suchen uns das Drama, beziehungsweise oft wirft uns die Ligen, werfen uns eigentlich das Drama hin und wir reden dann darüber. Jetzt gehen wir ins Tal der Langeweile oder wie muss ich das verstehen, dass wir jetzt über Stagg-Brest reden, den neuntplatzierten mit neun Siegen, sechs Unentschieden und neun Niederlagen.
Ja, schade, dass sie kein ausgeglichenes Torverhältnis haben.
Aber ganz knapp. 32 geschlossene Tore, 34 Kassierte.
Das ist fast.
Ja, genau. Aber ich finde, es ist doch erwähnenswert. Denn was man bei Stagg-Brest auf jeden Fall anmerken muss, ist, dass ja in den letzten beiden Saisons auf jeden Fall viel über sie gesprochen werden konnte. Denn sie haben sich ja vor zwei Jahren total überraschend für die Champions League qualifiziert, sind da auf einem überragenden dritten Platz gelandet. Und dann haben sie ja in der letzten Saison auch eine absolut fantastische Champions League Runde gespielt, da haben die Gruppen- oder Liga-Phase ja sogar überlebt und sind dann ja in den Playoffs gegen PSG ausgeschieden, das ist dann ja auch relativ krachend. Aber trotzdem war das natürlich für diesen Verein ein Riesenerfolg, denn man muss bei ihnen sagen, sie sind jetzt trotz dieser Ausreißer nach oben schon weiterhin eine der kleineren Mannschaften in der Liga und können sich auch so vom Budget her definitiv in der unteren Tabellenhälfte ansiedeln. Dementsprechend ist da jetzt ein neunter Platz, auch überhaupt kein Drama, zumal man jetzt auch in den letzten Wochen wirklich wieder eine deutlich bessere Form hatte. Man hatte zu Saisonbeginn durchaus ein bisschen Probleme, muss dazu aber auch sagen, dass man im Sommer unglaublich viel Substanz verloren hat. Also man hat mit Pierre Lesmeloux einen der absoluten Führungsspieler verloren, Lyon Brassier, ein Stammspieler in der Innenverteidigung, Marco Bisott, der Stammkeeper, Mady Kamara, einer der kreativen Mittelfeldspieler, dann mit Zima noch eine Laie von Brighton, der auch viele Tore gemacht hatte, Romain Fèvre, der zu Lyon gewechselt ist. Also je nachdem, wie man sieht, mindestens fünf, sechs, sieben Stammspieler verloren vor der Saison. Und dafür ist das halt absolut solide, was sie jetzt auch wieder spielen. Es gab so zu Saisonbeginn ganz kurz mal den Gedanken, ob sie vielleicht unten reinrutschen können. Da standen sie auch eine Zeit lang nicht gut da. Allerdings haben auch die Leistungen auf dem Platz damals schon darauf hingedeutet, dass sie sich eigentlich befreien müssten. Und man muss dazu sagen, dass es im Verein auch eine große Ruhe gibt. Der Trainer Eric Roy ist jetzt seit Anfang 2023 schon im Amt. Also für die heutigen Verhältnisse ja schon eine Ewigkeit, jetzt über drei Jahre da auf jeden Fall. Und ja, leistet auch gute Arbeit. Und was ich gerade noch vergessen habe bei den Abgängen, dass sie die halt auch nicht nennenswert ersetzen, also nicht gleichwertig ersetzen können mit den Möglichkeiten. Die sie haben, das ist ja in Frankreich bei vielen Vereinen so, aber es ist hier definitiv nochmal zu erwähnen. Und ja, das produziert dann halt auch so ein paar ganz schöne Geschichten, dass man zum Beispiel auf der Suche nach einem Ersatz im Tor hatte man erst mal Jetski von Monaco ausgeliehen. Der hat aber wirklich einen ganz, ganz fürchterlichen Saisonstart hingelegt, ist jetzt auf der Bank seitdem und wurde dann durch Grégoire Coudère ersetzt, der jetzt mit 26 plötzlich die Nummer 1 ist, nachdem er eigentlich in seiner ganzen Karriere bisher immer nur 2. oder 3. Kraft war und jetzt so aus dem absoluten Nichts gekommen ist. Der hatte, glaube ich, vor der Saison fünf Erstligaspiele gemacht oder so und spielt jetzt eine super solide Runde, hat, glaube ich, die drittbeste Safe-Percentage in der Liga. Also da hat man das dann auch intern gut gelöst und Einnahme bei Brest, über den ich auf jeden Fall noch sprechen möchte, wo wir vorhin bei Startrennen über Norden gesprochen haben, brauchen wir jetzt den nächsten Ex-Mainzer. Das ist Ludovic Ajorg, der in Frankreich so ein ziemlicher Kult-Spieler ist. Also allein auch aufgrund seiner Statur natürlich irgendwie schon so ein Spieler, der viele fasziniert und der hat auch in der Hinrunde schon gezeigt, dass er wichtig ist für Brest, da allerdings jetzt von den Statistiken ja gar nicht so krass performt, gerade vorm Tor, hatte er durchaus auch seine Probleme. Ich glaube, generell von der Spielweise hat man das ja auch in der Bundesliga gesehen, dass es ein wahnsinniges physisches Monster ist. Also der gewinnt, glaube ich, über 55 Prozent seiner Zweikämpfe, was ja für einen Stürmer eine grandiose Bilanz ist, zieht auch wahnsinnig viele Fouls, hat auch schon acht gelbe Karten bekommen, weil er selber gerne viel foult und halt einfach eine absolute Wucht ist im Sturm. Und jetzt in den letzten Spielen klappt es plötzlich aber auch vor dem Tor wieder. Er hat jetzt in 2.26 fünf Tore und drei Assists gesammelt, ist also einer der formstärksten Spieler oder Stürmer Europas momentan, kann man so sagen, und ist tatsächlich auch mit acht Assists in der ganzen Saison der beste Vorlagengeber in der Ligue 1. Also das ist definitiv auch ein Aspekt, der nicht zu unterschätzen ist und den man jetzt auch bei ihm vielleicht nicht so unbedingt erwartet hätte. Und ein Gedanke, den ich dann noch dabei hatte, dass der wahrscheinlich auch ganz gut zum Spielstil von Urs Fischer passen würde. Also wenn der im Sommer nicht von Mainz weggegangen wäre.
Ja, stimmt, da hättest du die Tits nicht holen müssen.
Genau.
Ja, das ist natürlich, ja, solche Geschichten schreibt ausschließlich der Fußball. Ich versuche gerade hier seine Luftstatistiken in einen europäischen Gesamtkontext zu setzen. Aber ja, heute ist der Wurm drin, die Seite lädt nicht. Ach, guck mal, ja, doch, er ist in den Top 5 Ligen. Liegt er auf Platz 4 bei den geführten Kopfball-Duellen und auch bei den gewonnenen Kopfball-Duellen, das reiche ich gerade nach. Weißt du, wer auf Rang 3 liegt, Jakob?
Philipp Tietz.
Auf Rang 2 übrigens Andre Ilic. Also gut, so viel dazu. Vielleicht hat Urs Fischer dann doch seinen Urs-Fischer-Spieler bekommen, haben wir ja auch schon so erwähnt. Und bei den gewonnenen Kopfball-Duellen ist tatsächlich Ashok auf Rang 3, Philipp Tietz dann nur auf einen Rang 7. Und da liegen, ja, da liegt ein ganzer Kopfball statistisch gesehen dazwischen. Sehr schön, sehr, sehr schön. Stadbrest, hätte ich auch nicht gedacht, dass wir über die nochmal sprechen, aber ich habe es gesehen in der Liste, ich habe es euch ja auch geschrieben. Ich war direkt, direkt on fire. Und das ging mir auch so, Christian, als ich auf dein letztes italienisches Thema geblickt habe, denn on fire trifft sie eigentlich vielleicht auch schon ganz gut. Wir wollen mal über die Roma nochmal sprechen, ist schon eine Weile her. Was hat sich denn bei der Roma so getan? Wer die Tabelle lesen kann, sieht sie auf Platz 4. Logischerweise mit der Meisterschaft nichts mehr zu tun, denn das haben wir ja vorhin schon besprochen. Aber ein bisschen wechselhafter Ergebnisse jetzt zuletzt gehabt. Es ist schon eine ganze Weile her, dass man mal so eine Serie starten konnte.
Ja, haben dich die zwei Stichworte vielleicht ein bisschen geteased, die ich geschickt hatte.
Also eins mehr als das andere.
Also fangen wir mal kurz mit dem Sportlichen an. Gerade am vergangenen Wochenende ist Roma gegen Juve. Also für Roma, wenn es das Derby nicht gäbe, dann ist das Juve-Spiel das emotionalste im Jahr und das hat wirklich geliefert, war ein Riesenspektakel 3-3 eben und das war eine Riesen-Chance, die Roma dann liegen hat lassen. Du hast das gesagt, die Roma liegt immer noch auf Platz 4, also ist auch im Rennen und die Champions League-Ränge sehr gut unterwegs. Aber sie hat bis nicht lange vor Schluss 3-1 geführt gegen eine Juve-Mannschaft, die unter der Woche diese 120 äußerst emotionalen Minuten gegen Galatasaray hinter sich hatte. Und nicht nur emotional, sondern davon auch mehr als eine Stunde in Unterzahl war. Also und Roma hatte, weil die ja erst in der Europa League jetzt im Achtelfinale einstiegen, hatte die ganze Woche Zeit, sich eben rhythmustechnisch auf dieses Spiel vorzubereiten. Und da kam es jetzt schon überraschend, dass sie dann nach diesen 3-1-Führung weiterhin die beste Defensive der Liga, ich glaube mit die beste Defensive Europas, dass sie da spät noch den Ausgleich kassieren. Denn, hätte Roma dieses Spiel gewonnen, hätten sie Juve auf Minus 7 geschickt. Und das ist logisch schon was zu dem Zeitpunkt jetzt, 7 Punkte aufzuholen aus Juvesicht. Die wären dann sicher auch von der Moral her schwer getroffen worden nach diesem Galatasaray aus, nach all den Rückschlägen, die sie zuletzt gelegt haben. Also, das war jetzt eine Riesenchance für die Roma. Trotzdem sind sie ja weiterhin voll mit dabei. Malen wieder getroffen. Malen ist genau der Spieler, den Gasperini gebraucht hat. Ich glaube, er steht bei sechs Toren in sechs Spielen. Also offensiv durch ihn wirklich viel mehr konkret, was da jetzt im letzten Drittel passiert. Das passt. Aber worauf ich eigentlich hinaus wollte, ist, es gibt drum herum ganz interessante Aktualitäten. Nämlich zum einen das Thema Neues Stadion. Neues Stadion ist in Rom auch eines, das schon sehr lang diskutiert wird, wo sehr lang wenig passiert ist. Und jetzt aber ist ein entscheidender Schritt passiert, nämlich die Gemeinde von Rom hat das Stadionprojekt durchgewunken. Also die Fritkens, die Eigentümer, die US-Eigentümer, probieren ja auch schon lange eben sozusagen, den Standort auch durch ein neues Stadion aufzuwerten. Und jetzt hat wirklich vor kurzem die Gemeinde, also dieses Projekt hat jetzt erstmal grünes Licht bekommen. Das heißt, es geht jetzt wirklich in die Richtung, dass vielleicht schon 2030 das neue Stadion dann da stehen könnte. Das war jetzt wirklich ein entscheidender Faktor, weil es war in Rom extrem schwierig überhaupt ein Areal zu finden. Sozusagen viele Projekte sind daran schon gescheitert. Und jetzt ist eben da grünes Licht von der Stadt sozusagen da. Dementsprechend geht das wirklich jetzt in eine heiße Richtung. Ganz spannend, das Stadion soll ungefähr um die 66.000 Zuschauer Platz bieten. Und was ich mich schon besonders freue, es soll eine der größten Kurven Europas sein, mit 23.000 Mann und Frauen sozusagen in der Kurve. Und wer die Roma-Kurve kennt, jetzt schon im Olympico, ich würde sagen, eine der emotionalsten in ganz Europa. Also ich glaube, da haben sie die richtige Idee verfolgt sozusagen, auch dieses Kurven, die Sache, die Kurve aufzuwerten sozusagen, wird bei dem neuen Stadionprojekt da definitiv mitgegangen. Und also das würde ich mal sagen, eine schöne Nachricht, auch wirklich zeigt eben auch, dass die Fritkins, eben die Eigentümer da auch, wir hatten es ja vorhin bei Atalanta, dass es da nicht nur darum geht, Geld in den Kader zu stecken, sondern schon auch den ganzen Standort eben sozusagen, ja im Idealfall auf ein neues Niveau zu heben. Und die zweite Personalie, da werden jetzt logisch ein paar besonders drauf hören und ja, warum auch nicht, Francesco Totti.
Das war das zweite Stichwort. Ich gebe es dir zu. Standort fand ich schon ganz interessant, habe auch gleich noch eine Frage zu, aber jetzt sag mir, was mit Totti ist.
Genau. Ja, bei Totti war ja auch klar vor Jahren, also er hat ja schon mal eine kurze Funktion gehabt bei Palotta. Das war noch der erste US-amerikanische Eigentümer. Das war dann aber relativ schnell zu Ende, weil er mehr oder weniger da nur so eine Grußfunktion hatte, so eine Vertretungsfunktion, und das wollte er nicht. Und hat sich dann auch total zurückgezogen, hat aber damals schon gesagt, logisch, die Roma ist weiterhin in meinem Herzen und wer weiß, wenn mal neue Eigentümer da sind, dann reden wir wieder von neuen. Und jetzt ist es wirklich, es schaut sehr konkret aus, es gab in den letzten Monaten schon immer wieder mal so kleine Momente. Francesco Totti war plötzlich bei einem Roma-Heimspiel, das war schon ein erstes Signal, aber es gab es wirklich lange nicht mehr. Und sobald Totti im Stadion ist, dann geht in Romdorf-Lufunk auf 120 sozusagen. Und jetzt hatten wir vergangene Woche das erste offizielle Treffen zwischen Gasperini und Totti. Also es liegt immer näher, dass Totti jetzt wirklich wieder in den Club zurückkehrt. Die Frage ist eigentlich nur noch, in welcher Funktion. Gasperini hat sich jetzt auch schon öffentlich dazu geäußert, begrüßt das sehr. Und anscheinend was ganz spannend ist, es geht wohl darum, dass er wirklich auch nicht nur eine institutionelle Funktion übernimmt, sondern wirklich auch was sozusagen Manager-mäßiges. Es steht im Raum, dass er vielleicht Sportdirektor wird, also jetzt nicht so eine übergeordnete Figur, also auch wirklich was Transfer-Stunt betrifft, dass er da mitredet. Zur Erinnerung, Totti war die letzten Jahre, hat auch selbst eine Spieloperatoragentur gegründet, hat jetzt auch relativ viel in dem Segment gemacht, gerade mit jungen Spielern. Und es scheint also jetzt wirklich auf dem Weg zu sein, dass die Rückkehr zu Totti, zu Roma auch in einer aktiven und relativ starken Position kurz vorm Abschluss steht. Und ja, das befeuert logischerweise in Rom und im Roma-Ambiente alles.
Ja, also da ist jetzt auf jeden Fall Energie drauf. Aber um nochmal kurz auf das Stadion zurückzukommen, das wäre ja am selben Standort. Ersetzt es dann das Stadio Olimpico?
Nein, nein, nein, es ist. Darum ging es eben. Es ging anders als bei San Siro in Mailand. Das Olimpico ist ja auch in diesem ganz speziellen Ambiente. Da ist ja auch Foro Italico, wo zum Beispiel das Tennis-TP-Turnier stattfindet. Das ist ja wirklich dieser Olympiapereich, der ist sicherlich auch geschützt. Es ging immer darum, das Stadion auch an einem neuen Ort in Rom ausfindig zu machen. Die Gegend heißt jetzt Pietralta. Fragt mich jetzt bitte nicht, wo genau geografisch das in Rom dieser Ecke ist. Aber es geht nicht darum, das Olympico neu zu machen. Es wird ein völlig neues, komplettes Stadion in einem neuen Areal.
Und dann auch nur für die Roma.
Genau, nur für die Roma. Die Lazio hat zum Beispiel auch Stadion-Gedanken. Nicht nur Gedanken. Da geht es auch darum, einen idealen Platz zu finden. Also genau, es wird darauf auslaufen, dass es irgendwann vielleicht, falls Lazio es ausschafft, dann wirklich auch zwei Stadionen jeweils für das eine Team in Rom gibt.
Also man spricht aktuell von 1,5 Milliarden Baukosten. Aber wenn das alles kommt, dann ist es jetzt erstmal nur der erste wichtige Schritt gegangen. Da werden wir da eh noch häufig genug drüber sprechen. Und ich sage euch, und das kommt ja ganz eindeutig vor allem aus Deutschland, dieses Orientieren an vielen Stehplätzen. Also dass du eben versuchst, so eine einheitliche Kurve zu schaffen. Das meine ich jetzt komplett hierher. Stehplätze gibt es natürlich auch woanders. Aber dass du Stadien so konzipierst, alle haben erst versucht, die gelbe Wand zu imitieren. Und daher kommt das. Und ich sage euch, es wird in spätestens– was haben wir jetzt 2026? Also spätestens 2030, wenn angeblich der Stadion eröffnet wird, ich bin gespannt, dann wird es auch Stehplätze in UEFA-Wettbewerben geben. Es gibt keine Begründung mehr dafür. Es kommt alles nur von Heysel und so schrecklich Heysel war. Aber es wird kommen und mit jedem Stadion, das gebaut wird, mit eben so vielen Stehplätzen, wird das, glaube ich, wahrscheinlicher. Chris möchte noch was sagen.
Ja, nur dazu, in England wird jetzt auch wieder vermehrt auf Safe Standing geachtet. Also da kommt es jetzt auch allmählich zurück. Und da ist man ja auch am gebrannt marksten.
Genau. Und ja, und das ist eben einfach eine andere Situation jetzt. Plus du baust ja inzwischen auch Stehplatztribünen anders als noch früher. Also wenn ihr euch mal anguckt, wie Wellenbrecher und so weiter verteilt sind, wie anders Mundlöcher jetzt meistens konzipiert sind, dass es eben nicht mal so gewisse Effekte gibt, die es bei alten Stadien manchmal noch gab. Also ja, freue ich mich schon drauf, wenn wir das irgendwann auch mal wieder in UEFA-Wettbewerben haben. Stehplätze. Irgendwann wird die UEFA checken, aber wir können jetzt nicht nochmal mehr Teams reinholen in Champions League, um noch mehr Spiele zu machen. Und dann werden sie an solche Soft-Faktoren, an solche weichen Faktoren werden sie rangehen. Wir werden sagen, wäre es nicht geil, wenn wir irgendwie so schöne Bilder hätten wie in anderen. Natürlich Pyrro immer noch schlimm, schlimm schon schlimm, aber Stehplätze wollen wir jetzt haben. Naja, gut, aber das führt jetzt ein bisschen weit. Also ich bin absolut elektrisiert, Christian. Ich freue mich da so auf beides, also sowohl Stadion als auch Totti.
Das hat beides Potenzial, ja, definitiv.
Aber wirklich, es ist einfach einer der grandiosesten Fußballspieler, die ich in meinen Lebzeiten halt erlebt habe. Und zwar quasi so als Gesamtkonstrukt. Und gar nicht nur sportlich, sondern einfach so das Gesamtding, ja. Gut, aber bevor ich jetzt...
Nee, aber deswegen auch noch ein letzter Satz dazu. Es ist schon besonders spannend, weil logisch die Figur Totti, die wird ja auch im Ausland oft so wahrgenommen. Ich glaube, als Spieler können sich relativ viele darauf einigen. Aber logisch war schon auch die Frage danach, was ist er denn zu leisten im Stande? Also was kann er auch so einem Club sozusagen jetzt wirklich geben, außer seinem Namen und seinem Gesicht? Und deswegen ist das jetzt, glaube ich, wird es auch für ihn, wenn es wirklich in die Richtung geht, dass er da eine aktive Rolle bekommt, ist das jetzt schon für ihn auch sowohl eine Riesenchance, aber sicherlich auch, er muss dann auch beweisen, dass er sowas auch ausführen kann, weil ja, vielleicht hat er nicht oft die Chance bekommen, vielleicht hat er sie sich auch manchmal hin und wieder auch ein bisschen selbst zunichte gemacht. Also das wäre jetzt wirklich sowohl Chance als auch sicherlich auch ein gewisses Risiko. Kann Francesco Totti eben neben seinem Namen, neben seinem Gesicht auch inhaltlich seinem Herzensverein was geben. Also deswegen, da werden wir dranbleiben.
Wir schauen es uns auf jeden Fall genau an. Und dann wollen wir auch mal indirekt auf Manchester United blicken, Chris. Denn das haben ja die Hörerinnen und Hörer sicherlich mitbekommen. Die hatten jetzt eine irre ungeschlagen Serie. Wir haben ja hier auch schon mal thematisiert, bzw. ich glaube, wir haben es thematisiert, ob da vielleicht sogar mal fünf Siege in Folge klappen und der Friseur angerufen werden muss. Dem ist jetzt nicht so gekommen. Man hat jetzt auch gegen Newcastle trotz Überzahl verloren, jetzt unmittelbar vor dieser Sendung. Aber dennoch steht Manchester United viel, viel besser da als noch vor einigen Wochen. Man liegt auf Rang 3 in der Premier League. Und es gibt vor allem einen Spieler, der läuft gerade heiß, so wie ich beim Thema Roma und Totti. Wer ist es und warum?
Genau, Benjamin Cesco. Ich dachte, nachdem man schon zu genüge über Voltemade, RKTK etc. gesprochen hat, lohnt es sich vielleicht auch, über Cesco zu reden und wie er sich in der Premier League so schlägt. Du hast es bereits gesagt, seitdem Carrick da ist und United wieder in die Spur gekommen ist, ist auch Cesco durchgestartet. Sieben Tore in den letzten zehn Spielen. Kein Premier League-Spieler hat in englischen Wettbewerben in diesem Jahr mehr Tore erzielt. Und davor waren es eben zwei Tore in 16. Da sieht man schon die Wände. Davor gab es Knieprobleme, Anpassungsprobleme, Amorins-Fußballprobleme und jetzt startet er durch. Und man muss auch sagen, es hat sich schon lange angedeutet. Also selbst in den schlechten Phasen von Man United ist Cesco aufgefallen durch klasse Bewegungen, super Laufwege. Also man kennt ja seine Attribute auch aus der Bundesliga. Es war, glaube ich, auch immer nur eine Frage, ob er wirklich dieser geschliffene Spieler werden kann, weil, wie gesagt, er ein ungeschliffener Diamant gewesen, hohe Attribute, alles da, alles, er hat alles, was ein Stürmer braucht, die Athletik, die Schnelligkeit, Kopfballstärke, also all das ist da. Und ich finde es ziemlich beachtlich, was er auch an Arbeitsethos besitzt. Denn ich weiß nicht, ob die Geschichte von Leipzig bekannt ist, als ihm sogar dieses Armbändchen für den Fitnessraum abgenommen wurde, weil er es fast schon übertrieben hat. Dazu hat er jetzt bei Man United, da gab es eine kurze 13-tägige Pause während der Saison, weil man aus den Wettbewerben ausgeschieden war. Da waren die Spieler teilweise in Dubai. Und Sesko hat die Zeit genutzt, um da bei einem Spezial-Trainingsprogramm teilzunehmen und hat wirklich an jedem Tag trainiert. Und er hat daheim auch noch so einen LED-Reflex-Trainer, ein Fußballfeld, ein Virtual Reality Headset. Also er investiert unfassbar viel. Und da ist es auch schön zu sehen, dass die Arbeit sich lohnt. Und ja, also aktuell scheint diese Wette, die Man United im Sommer aufgenommen hat, für 77 Millionen tatsächlich aufzugehen. Denn wenn er wirklich sein Potenzial erfüllt, dann wird er diese Summe auf jeden Fall wert sein.
Mir hat jemals, als damals Benjamin Sesko zu Leipzig gewechselt ist, da hat mir jemand gesagt aus der Bundesliga, wenn der gesund bleibt, dann wird es ein Top-5-Stürmer Europas. Und alles, was du jetzt sagst, zahlt darauf ein, die Quote zahlt darauf ein und das Alter. 22 Jahre ist er ja erst jung. Das ist ja irre. Und wie der es geschafft hat, das war für mich so das größte Fragezeichen, wie schnell bekommt er die Athletik hin, um sich eben in der halt viel athletischeren Premier League durchzusetzen. Und zugegeben, ich habe jetzt vor allem die Tore gesehen, habe jetzt nicht spielüber 90 Minuten gesehen. Aber da hatte ich den Eindruck, es ist kein Problem. Alles, was du so erzählst, klingt auch danach.
Ja, absolut. Also da gab es ja diesen einen Sprint gegen Everton war es, glaube ich, wo er wirklich irre schnell über das gesamte Feld durchgestartet ist und abgeschlossen hat. Jetzt gegen Crystal Palace, ein Kopfballtor, bei dem er wirklich in der Luft steht. Also man sieht, die Tore fallen unterschiedlich. Und das einzige Fragezeichen war ja auch teilweise ein bisschen der Abschluss, nicht wegen der Technik, sondern ich glaube einfach, weil er noch nicht so die Coolness hatte vom Tor. Und wenn du jetzt die Tore siehst, ist es eiskalt mit einer irren Geschwindigkeit ins Netz befördert. Also das funktioniert auch allmählich. Also ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass er sein Potenzial wirklich jetzt erfüllen wird, wenn es so weitergeht.
Ja und auch da wieder ganz kurz aus Italien. Also das Paket haben sie auch in Italien sehr gesehen. Ich weiß zum Beispiel, dass Milan alles probiert hat. Aber dann war klar, als die Premier League-Summen im Spiel waren, war klar, dass man da nicht mitgehen kann. Aber Milan hat den auch schon in dem Jahr davor schon auf dem Zettel gehabt. Da gab es auch schon Überlegungen. Ja, am Ende, klar, gegen die Finanzmacht aus der Premier League war da nichts zu holen. Aber das Paket war definitiv auch bei den großen Italienern absolut schon weit oben auf dem Zettel. Und schön, dass das anscheinend in die Richtung auch geht. Und wie ihr sagt, also 22 ist schon krass, finde ich. Gerade bei so einem Spielertyp, so einem Neuner, also da kann noch sehr viel kommen. Ich glaube, wir sind uns alle einig, wenn der gesund bleibt.
Es gibt aber noch ein Aber beziehungsweise eine Frage, die ich habe, Chris. Also jetzt hat er vier Tore in den letzten sechs Spielen zum Beispiel gemacht, aber hat auch nur in einem Spiel jetzt eben gegen Newcastle über 90 Minuten gespielt. Warum wird er derzeit nur eingewechselt?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Gegen Man City saß sogar das ganze Spiel auf der Bank. Und ab da kam er dann mehr zum Einsatz. Ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass es auch ein bisschen an der Ausrichtung von Michael Carrick liegt, denn man ist zwar wieder an die Spur gekommen, aber wenn man sich die Spiele ansieht, so unfassbar überzeugend war das jetzt nicht unbedingt. United ist eher wieder an die Spur gekommen, weil man sich ein bisschen wieder auf die Basics fokussiert hat, was Amorim einfach komplett das Gegenteil gemacht hat, viel zu verkopft. Und es ging halt, glaube ich, mehr um eine defensive Grundausrichtung, um gut in Konton zu sein und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass es ein bisschen an der Defensivarbeit liegt.
Okay, wir werden wir weiter beobachten, aber das wird natürlich in Zukunft die Diskussion werden. Man muss natürlich auch sagen, man hat da sehr unterschiedliche Spielerprofile. Also, Mateusz Kunja spielt ja quasi nominell die Spitze in den Spielen, in denen Cescun nicht auftritt. Also, muss jetzt, glaube ich, nicht viel zu sagen, dass die unterschiedliche Spieler sind, das weiß man. Und die interpretieren ihre Rolle auch anders. Und deswegen, vielleicht muss da Kerik auch noch, also ich glaube, er passt manchmal auch auf die Gegner an. Zumindest sieht es für mich so aus, wenn ich mir jetzt einfach nur die Startaufstellungen angucke. Und ja, aber das ist eben, macht es ja eigentlich noch krasser, dass Cescun trotzdem so viele Tore geholt hat, mit eben noch weniger Spielzeit. Also, behaltet den Namen im Hinterkopf, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und ich kannte die Leipzig-Geschichte noch nicht mit dem Fitness-Armbändchen. Sehr, sehr schön. Dann blicken wir auch nochmal in die Ligue 1, Jakob. Denn da gibt es ja noch eine große Titelfrage, die nicht geklärt ist. Meisterschaft haben wir ja vorhin schon im Grunde zugemacht, auch wenn es offiziell noch nicht so ist. Aber der viel, viel spannendere Titel ist ja ein anderer.
Genau. Die Coupe de France ist nämlich noch offen. Da läuft jetzt– also nicht jetzt, während wir aufnehmen, aber gerade unter dieser Woche läuft– laufen die Viertelfinals. Drei von vier sind durch. Und wir hatten, glaube ich, ganz kurz das vor ein paar Wochen schon mal angerissen, dass ja Paris schon ausgeschieden ist. Auch schon vor zwei Runden damals ja gegen den Stadtrivalen Paris FC. Und somit steht hier auch fest, dass PSG nicht die dritte Coupe de France in Folge gewinnen wird. Ich finde, die Coupe de France ist schon so ein ganz besonderer Wettbewerb. Es macht mir immer riesig Spaß, das zu verfolgen. Auch wenn jetzt, seitdem die Qatar in Paris investiert hat, schon die Dominanz von PSG relativ groß ist. Man hat jetzt von den letzten 11 Ausgaben acht gewonnen. Allerdings immerhin von in den letzten vier Jahren nur zweimal. Es gab dann auch zwei, ich glaube, man kann es so sagen echte Überraschungssieger. Es war dann nicht so, wie es in Deutschland häufig ist, dass dann eines der nächstgrößeren Teams den Titel abgreift. Sondern es war dann 21-22 Nont und 22-23 Toulouse. Also zwei Teams, die jetzt eigentlich auch in der Tabelle wirklich nicht, zumindest nicht um die Champions League-Plätze mitspielen in den letzten Jahren. Und generell, es, finde ich, gibt sehr, sehr viele Überraschungen. Wir hatten zum Beispiel im letzten Jahr ein verrücktes Halbfinale. Da war ein Viertligist, ein Zweitligist und mit Stade Rennes ein Team, was ja später auch abgestiegen ist aus der Ligue 1 im Halbfinale. Und dann waren in den vorherigen Runden extrem viele Erstligisten auch gegen unterklassige Teams ausgeschieden. Und das ist auch tatsächlich jetzt in Frankreich eher die Regel als die Ausnahme. Also es gibt jetzt in den letzten 20 Jahren gab es zahlreiche Dritt-, Viert-, Fünftligisten, die es sogar teilweise bis ins Finale geschafft haben in der Coupe de France. Und das ist dann schon etwas, was den Pokal, glaube ich, von vielen anderen Pokalen in den anderen Ländern auch unterscheidet. Dass da wirklich diese Sensationsdichte relativ hoch ist und dass die unterklassigen Teams dann auch teils wirklich extrem weit schaffen können. Das ist in dieser Saison jetzt anders. Man hat zwar den großen Favoriten raus, allerdings hat man im Halbfinale jetzt auch nur Erstligisten und hatte auch schon im Viertelfinale mit Stadranz nur ein Team aus der zweiten Liga, die aber auch da oben mitspielen. Also das war jetzt nicht so ungewöhnlich, was aber durchaus bemerkenswert ist, dass jetzt auch von den verbliebenen Teams eigentlich fast alle sehr, sehr lange auf einen Titel warten. Man hatte jetzt gestern die Situation, dass es zwei Spiele gab, die erst im Elfmeterschießen entschieden wurden. Einmal hat es Nizza gegen Lorient weitergekommen und dann ist Toulouse gegen Marseille weitergekommen. Und Toulouse ist jetzt auch das einzige Team, das wirklich in der kürzeren Vergangenheit einen von den nennenswerten Titeln gewonnen hat. Man hat mit Straßburg noch den anderen schon feststehenden Halbfinalisten, die am 18.19. immerhin mal den Liga-Pokal gewonnen, der allerdings natürlich auch eine etwas kleinere Rolle spielt. Auch wenn der damals in Frankreich noch eigentlich wieder Pokal ausgetragen wurde. Es war nicht so, dass dann nur zwei, drei Teams gegeneinander gespielt haben, sondern es war schon auch ein bisschen wie der League Cup in England. Den gibt es allerdings auch jetzt nicht mehr. Und der echte Pokalsieg bei Straßburg ist jetzt auch schon über 20 Jahre her. Und genau, Nizza, die jetzt auch fürs Halbfinale qualifiziert sind, haben letztmals 96, 97 den Pokal gewonnen. Also auch da ist eine lange Titellosigkeit. Wir hatten kurz darüber gesprochen, dass ja eigentlich Marseille sich diesen Wettbewerb jetzt ausgeguckt hatte, um die Titelflaute zu beenden. Das hat jetzt mit dem Aus gestern auch nicht geklappt. Und heute Abend spielen noch Lyon und Lens gegeneinander. Auf der einen Seite Lyon, die ja in den Nullerjahren die riesige Dominanz hatten, wo sie Titel um Titel geholt haben. Jetzt aber auch seit ja 12.13, wo sie den Supercup gewonnen haben und 11.12, wo sie den Pokal gewonnen haben, titellos sind. Und Lens, die natürlich, wenn es jetzt tatsächlich nicht für die Meisterschaft reichen sollte, zumindest den Pokal holen könnten. Und auch die haben den Pokal tatsächlich noch nie gewonnen, haben letztes Mal 97, 98 die Meisterschaft geholt und dann im Jahr darauf den Liga-Pokal. Also es wird, außer es wird to lose. Und selbst da wäre es auch eine große Überraschung, weil die sind auch im Mittelfeld der Liga. Wird es auf jeden Fall einen Titelträger geben, der dann eine lange Titellosigkeit beenden kann.
Ach, sehr schön. Spielt eure Pokale nicht in Hin- und Rückspiel. Einfach nur ein Spiel. Dann ist sowas leichter.
Und keine Verlängerung.
Ach ja, stimmt. Genau deswegen geht es so oft ins Elfmeterschießen. Das hatte ich gerade schon wieder vergessen. Ja, okay. Und das hat man wahrscheinlich in Marseille, hat man das durch zur Kenntnis genommen, das verlorene Elfmeterschießen.
Total, ja. Vor allem, weil man auch schon wieder zweimal geführt hat und schon wieder zu Hause zwei Gegentore kassiert hat. Also super. Javi Bey ist jetzt auch mit zwei verschiedenen Teams aus dem Pokal ausgeschieden, nachdem er ja auch für das Aus von Startrennen verantwortlich war. Ich glaube, das gab es auch für ein League-Ein-Team noch nie tatsächlich.
Oh man, aber es ist schön zu sehen, dass es überall dann doch noch irgendwie spannende Wettbewerbe gibt. Man kann es wirklich nur weiterempfehlen. Also den Coupe de France, wenn er das jetzt hier noch am Donnerstag hört, um 21.10 Uhr am heutigen Donnerstag, den 5.3., wird eben zwischen Lyon und Lens gespielt. Wo man es sehen kann, weiß ich gerade nicht, aber irgendwie kriegt man es ja. Na klar, wäre ich jetzt auch drauf gekommen, wenn ich mir das hier dran lasse. Was weiß denn ich? Was ich weiß, ist, dass das wirklich eine sehr, sehr schöne Folge war. Mir hat es besonders Spaß gemacht, dass wir so ein bisschen Luft hatten, auch wirklich Diskussionen laufen zu lassen. Das war wirklich, wirklich schön. Ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank an Christian Bernhard, an Jakob Haffke und an Chris McCarthy. Danke euch dreien.
Danke schön.
Danke dir.
Und ich danke natürlich auch euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, denn ihr wisst ja, ihr macht alles hier möglich im Rasenfunk. Der Rasenfunk ist frei von Werbung, frei von Sponsoren und auch frei von einer Paywall. Gerade so eine Sendung hier, wie so eine klassische Paywall-Sendung eigentlich. Aber das wollen wir nicht, denn wir wollen, dass alle den Zugriff haben auf alles, was wir jemals gemacht haben. Also das geht ja auch viele, viele Jahre jetzt schon zurück. Wie ist das möglich? Über nette Menschen, die uns freiwillig, ohne dass es irgendeinen Zwang gibt, unterstützen und das finanziell. Ihr findet in der Video- und der Podcast-Beschreibung, wie das geht. Es dauert auch wirklich nicht lange. Inzwischen haben wir auf unserer Homepage sogar einen dieser schicken QR-Codes. Da müsst ihr nur abscannen und dann könnt ihr uns einen Dauerauftrag einrichten oder eine Einmal-Überweisung zukommen lassen. Also schaut euch das sehr gerne an, wenn euch Sendungen wie diese hier gefallen haben. Verfolgt uns gerne auch in unseren anderen Feeds. Und in der Sendung möchte ich mich bedanken bei Jörg G7, bei Kicker's Emden Maniac, also wenn der nicht die Ligatour hört, dann weiß ich auch nicht, bei Sebastian 96 und bei Lest 1893. Ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank für eure Unterstützung. Und dann habe ich für alle Ligatour-Afficionados draußen noch einen weiteren Podcast-Tipp. Denn ihr könnt euch sehr gerne das Tribüning-Gespräch anhören, das ich aufgezeichnet habe am vorgestrigen Dienstag. Und zwar mit den beiden Hebelbrüdern. Und die sollten euch ein Begriff sein. Die haben ein Buch über sich schreiben lassen. Wir reden aber auch viel darüber, wie sie ihren Job interpretieren. Und da ich weiß, dass ihr Uli und Jogi mögt, sage ich, ihr werdet auch dieses Tribüning-Gespräch lieben. In diesem Sinne, hört es euch gerne an. Bleibt gesund, bis bald, ciao!
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen.
Vielen Dank!